dans un voyage dans mes rêves
que je fais lorsque je m'énerve je me
suis demandée question sexe pourquoi on
ferait par leur verse
en matière 4 n'en déplaise on parle 1
française
bonjour à tête
les enfants tu le sonn de grammaire
française la féminine l'emportait salah
masculine
grégoire commence pas pourquoi parce que
c'est comme ça
alors
si on met dans une salle mettons cent
mille hommes et une bougie on dit il
sans bryant à part au ceba maghrébins
où elles sont brillantes un
brillant travail j'ai mis mes oui parce
que quel que soit le nombre eux mêmes un
fim et deux sujets masculins dans un
groupe nominal l'acia l'ia ne serait ce
qu'une juge est féminine et même si
c'est une aube jacques pape elles
l'emportent sur eux tous tpt
c'est pour ça que j'ai dit bonjour à
tout en arrivant tu
es les hommes ne s'en sont pas sentis
lésés
alors j'aurais pu j'aurais pu dire
bonjour à toutes et à tous on va pas
doubler tous les maux
ne vous laissez pas influencer les
enfants tu par idéologie inclusive
d'ailleurs les mots au tri sa doctoresse
conviennent et suffisent pour désigner
les femmes et les quelques hommes qui
exercent des professions
masculinistes sont là ils en vendent des
mots genre hauteur
du
voyez c'est moche
comme la gent féminine est aussi là
genre un oeil très peu et c'est pour
cela que nous pouvons dire par exemple
chanceuse nous la somme qu'elle fasse
belle dehors
ça choque que nous sommes à rennes
voilà c'est pour cela aussi qu'à
l'affrontement de la pente et hommes
elle y as écrite aux grands de femmes la
matrice reconnaissante
alors est-ce que vous avez d'autres
idées à gregor baisse alors je ne vois
pas tes camarades homme gémit oui elle
était une fois dans les comptes là elle
est un autre en même temps c'est logique
hein une fois qu'elle était qu on
n'allait tout de même pas dire il était
une fois grotesque
à la limite on pourrait dire ils étaient
1 x tu vois jay gore te fais pas de bile
est-ce que moi est-ce que vous avez
d'autres idées
corinne
absatou km sûr je comprends toujours
alors
les droits de la femme oui alors les
québécoises traduit cette expression
mean streets par droits des personnes
humaines droit de lemay n'a pas de quoi
heureusement en france déesse merci
on a gardé cette tradition
révolutionnaire de lire droits de la
femme période de covin comme ça c'est
particulièrement de fans à dire
non grégoire s'est pas sexiste parce
qu'on a une astuce
on ajoute une f majuscule
et ma jument juillet femme se met à
désigner femmes et hommes
elodie des on dit jamais mais c'est sans
jeu ni justement voilà on ré ou sans
maux qui nous désignent pour leur faire
croire qu'on parle de 6,2 à a
tu comprends tout hein tu seras ministre
s comme un
génie à blanc coeur
+3 points d'ailleurs ta maman ministre
de l'éducation
veut interdire à l'école la
propagation de cette pandémie
qui menace d'extinction la française
ce fléau des militants
prostatique comme
masculine asie
avec leurs poings médisants point dément
en point médian je ne sais pas écrire en
morse
leur écriture un cultive
et pillent obscène c'est du doubs péri
le moteur
un délire
ouais ouais voilà c'est un sketch on ne
rigole 1
sauf que aujourd'hui en france à l'école
les élèves entendent encore cette
sentence le masculin en porte sur le
féminin
pourquoi dans la réalité on n'en est pas
tout autant te choquer c'est pourtant
que la même chose hein mais est en vrai
et en inversé nuisant à ou l'autre
moitié de l'humanité pas en matriarcat
tu mets en patriarcat à la fin de mes
spectacles mais conférence mais
formation les femmes viennent me dire
qu'elle aussi se souviennent de cette
leçon de g merci peut-être vous aussi
le masculin l'emportent dans ma tête de
petites filles et sa vrille
comment ne pas comprendre qu'ils veulent
que les garçons l'emportent sur les
filles je me sentais trahi par une
langue que je croyait jusqu'ici ma
meilleure amie parce que j'avais
remarqué et déjà que ma force à moi
contre les maux ne serait point de
manier les points mais de manier les
mots pour faire lever les poings
contre les injustices de l'existence je
voulais marc mais d'une juste éloquence
or
exister en écrivant tu est ce possible
quand même les mots boue rendent
invisibles
peut-on parler pour libérer les opprimés
si la langue érigé en règle l'iniquité
pouvait jamais exprimé de manière
égalitaire avec comme ennemi infiltré
la grammaire
en 2012 pour rendre justice aux femmes
héroïnes soeur vivante que dans les
luttes j'ai rencontré jean tam compte à
rebours l'écriture de ma pièce de
théâtre réécriture féministes des contes
de fées et là c'est le drame
quelle est cette première phrase qui
débute tout content avec emphase
il était une fois quoi sans dec était ce
il ce mec qui comptaient par deux en
tête de mes comptes il me couper des
ailes rendez vous compte là c'était trop
pour moi leurs règles je les mettrai à
bas quitte à écrire sans foi ni loi
j'écrivis cent fois comme on reprend ses
droits elle était une fois ainsi
naissait rebelles la féminine
universel
cette langue je l' ai créé et fait
évoluer comme c'est mon droit de
féministes et d'artistes une littéraire
comme la peintre est ce c'est couleurs
choisies son vocabulaire comme la chef
c'est saveurs sublime sa grammaire
et si elle féminine universel
aujourd'hui est largement entreprise
déploie ses ailes au départ croyez moi
j'étais bien solitaire qu'est ce que
c'est que ce bazar le masculin aux
portes dont la grammaire toi un
point
final au point
cardinal
des années plus tard je rencontrais
aurore et 20 la chercheuse portait en
étendard des mots qui m'ouvre est un
destin mots que jadis j'avais cherché en
vain
désespérée que ni odeur ni écrivain ne
puisse rimer avec tiphaine or aurore
disait aux tris
écrivaine et ces mots là elle ne les
avait pas inventé elle les avait
retrouvés car pendant des siècles et des
siècles ainsi on avait nommé les femmes
qui créent et écrivait écrivaine et
autres ismes aux délices qui me nommait
alors j'existais et aurore nous rendait
encore ce mot matrimoine
car les infâmes nous avaient dérobé
jusqu'au moyen de nommer l'héritage
culturel des femmes la tâche de
l'effacer ensuite on n'en a été que plus
aisés
ainsi j'apprenais aussi grâce à i lya ne
vienne aut
l'histoire cachée du rapt de nos maux la
disparition de la forme féminine des
noms de métiers prestigieuse et hautes
fonctions dont l'utilisation était
pourtant deux millénaires et jusqu'à la
masculinisation de toute la grammaire
avait donc été une décision
mûrement réfléchie politique
masculinistes en
inique d'attentes des années 1630
le cardinal de richelieu sous louis xiii
avait créé l'académie française pour que
les français l'emportent sur les
françaises et les conséquences en sont
toujours tellement de fortes
car je vais vous dire un secret
quand on fait disparaître un mot cela a
pour effet d'effacer du même coup les
possibles qu'il porte
le langage structure la pensée 6 dans
chacune formulé l art vais intégrer
l'infériorité des femmes et la
supériorité des hommes
propagande banalisé normalisé jusque
dans nos propres tête mesdames alors
nous sommes spoliés 7 un continuum de
l'empathie qui les empêche de commettre
des violences et de l'empathie qui
permet les qualité comme des moyens de
nous émanciper
parler de manière oppressive ses pensées
de manière oppressive
et les pensées entraîne les actions
partout ils ont gravé fraternité et nous
ont dérobé sororité comment alors mes
soeurs même penser et nous rassemblés
brandissant ridicule leur muette
majuscule si toujours ils proclament les
droits de l'homme comment s'étonner que
régulièrement il gomme et dégomme les
droits des femmes
dans un monde fait d'auteurs sans autre
hills ou l'ambassadrice n'est que
l'épousé de l'ambassadeur
nous ne pouvons enfants te pleinement te
rêvé d' exercer ces métiers
nous souffrons alors du syndrome de
l'imposteur is dont les symptômes nous
font sentir illégitime dérisoire sur ce
qui reste leur territoire le cardinal et
ses amis de l'académie
voulait les femmes procréatrice non
créatis
récréative non créative
et refusé de reconnaître
le mot
féminicide
s'est refusé de reconnaître les
féminicides
c'est nier les victimes
et s'est maquillé ses crimes misogyne
politique systémique en fait divers et
querelles intime
alors certains par exemple figaro nomme
la nécessaire d masculinisation du
langage un fléau qui pioche dans un
lexique à bibliques comme si l'écriture
inclusive et qui volait une invasion de
criquets
mais pour cela qu'ils prétendent garder
une grammaire de domination sous
prétexte de ce qu leurs traditions
questions pratiques utiles toujours
aussi les saignées et l'uriné potion
ceux qui veulent toujours faire comme on
faisait dans le temps comme par exemple
eric zemmour aux ide
soyaux t-il aussi le coup vide avec une
poire ne m'en
suis j'ai été mieux avant tu jolie et
bien tester l'arrachage de dents sans
anesthésie
à l'instar des académiciens entre eux
coopté tout ce qui est vieux n'est pas à
conserver
sa les immortels hurle du berry le
modèle e contre la française fadaises
puéril que dirait-il de ma féminine
universel à leur ferait avoir des
infarctus augustin
pourtant elle ne consiste en l'espèce
que leur rendre la monnaie de leur pièce
je vous conseille de l'essayer les
potesses la féminine universel amazon
élargit nos horizons et nous redresse
alors que les attaques des réacs fusent
j'accuse le cardinal de richelieu et ses
petits copains aux fraises vieux
incompétent de l'académie nabeul d'être
bien ceux qui l'ont perverti abîmée de
manière considérable elle y a quatre
cents ans la langue française
et je vous le dis nous n'avons plus à
obéir à un cardinal décédé
parler comme madame de sévigné n'est
point pour nous déshonorer elle écrivait
main lors de jeux l'insu il se fit aux
réformes et indigeste de l'académie
est aussi rendons femmes âge
non je n'ai pas dit fromage je suivais
gagnent
rendons femmes âge un os résistante
révolutionnaire qui proclamait déjà en
1792 naguère le genre masculin ne sera
plus regardées même dans la grammaire
comme le genre noble attendu que tous
les genres tous les sexes et tous les
êtres doivent être et sont également tno
bhl
1792 car ouiiii l'écriture inclusive
c'est d'abord de les voir revenir à la
langue historique de nos mémoires celle
de nos racines celles de racines et de
marguerite de navarre et puis c'est une
régal l'accord de proximité rend les
hommes et les femmes égal et les femmes
et les hommes égaux l'accord de majorité
est mathématique
démocratique et personne n'y comptent
plus pour 0 et l'accord de choix
enchante poétesse et poète choisissent
leurs rimes comme ça les chante
carnon l'écriture inclusive me se résume
le point au point médian qui n'est
qu'une proposition
facultative draps d'abréviations al
écrite piennes pratique si on veut
gagner du temps sans que cela n'affole
le général de gaulle s'il vous plaît
déjà utilisait la double fonction
entrée 9 en ré et bienne nous proposons
si l'on souhaite l'écrire plus en
vitesse les français point médian us et
s'ils ont peu varié à son aise on peut
aussi parler du peuple ou de la
population française se sont moqués
personnes qui aux femmes comme aux
hommes conviennent
voilà
et leur père y est mort delmas est juste
ça
n'allait pas s'affoler
la langue française est équipée pour
l'égalité n'en déplaise à
alain finkielkraut
et ses amis de l'académie d'auge et
inclusive s'est retrouvé les règles et
les mots d'origine légitime historique
plus simple car plus juste et logique
que celle de l'autre ecclésiastiques
et même je vais vous dire si les formes
féminines des noms de métiers n'avait
pas déjà existé par la passe et on les
aurait quand même inventé
si la messe comme si le masculin sur la
féminine l'avait toujours remporté de
toute éternité cette règle on se serait
quand même battu pour la changer quand
une règle est injuste on n'est pas tenu
de la respecter
[Applaudissements]
nos élites on peut parler écrire penser
et agir à égalité juste en être en toute
liberté
une femme
être une femme que cette chanson des
années 2020 blanc caire et académiciens
ne nous empêchera plus de rêver de
pratiquer tous les métiers être peintre
est souple et s écrivez-nous
philosophait ce professeur zhu ça peut
selon pierre metteuse en scène ou
plombières être soldate ou avocate
procure jugé ce magistrat présidente
lieutenant thomason dépenses des droits
des personnes
ambassadrice ou sofres artisanes ou
ingénieur hes entrepreneurs zoomer de
sienne un jour serait académicienne fin
un an semble être une femme
c'est fin
holmes être une femme
fin
être une femme être une femme être une
femme faut
mettre une femme être une femme être une
femme
ce qu'on peut dire on peut
la de venir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]